hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played yesterday in
round five of the military Champions
Chester finals it is Quang Liam Lee
versus Magnus Carlson and even though
Magnus is leading the tournament Quang
Liam Le uh defeated Yankees to do that
in the previous round and he is playing
some excellent chess uh so let's see how
this one turns out as this is game six
of their match so the the match started
in the rapid section of the of the match
Magna started by winning uh then Liam
retaliated in the second game games
three and four ended in a draw and this
is now the sixth game of Blitz Magnus
won the fifth game and now he only needs
a draw in this game uh in order to win
the match so let's see what happened uh
as this a little bit of information uh
does make the game all the more
interesting so uh Quang Liam opens with
Pawn to D4 we have Knight to F6 uh C4 we
have Pawn to E6 and now Knight to F3
with Bishop to B4 check going for the
BOGO Indian defense Bishop to D2 locking
check and now Bishop captures on D2
Queen captures on D2 and now Pawn to D5
we have Knights the C3 and here Magnus
Castle's King side we have Pawn to E3
and now B6 Queen to E7 uh is uh is also
possible but uh for some reason Magnus
decides to go B6 even though uh B6 has
not been played this year Queen t7 is
the main idea here B6 is sort of again
last year's move uh maybe testing if uh
if Liam uh knows his stuff in the BOGO
Indian so C captures on the five Knight
captures on the 5 and Rook to C1 with
Bishop to B7 and now Knight captures on
D5 and there is one game in the database
where Queen captures on D5 was played
and it is a nice move it brings the
queen and the worship to this diagonal
however it's easy to kick away the queen
with Bishop to C4 you basically give
white a free a free Tempo and even if
Queenie foreign simply Bishop to D3 so
the queen can't really remain on this
strong diagonal so instead Magnus just
plays Bishop captures on D5 and it is
not as of move 10 that we have a
completely new game uh Alien replies
with Bishop to D3 uh he wants to play
Queen to C2 and attack the H7 Pawn into
the C7 Pawn so that's why Magnus uh
plays H6 you could also play C5 it's
important to avoid this double attack so
H6 uh We've Queen to C2 now attacking C7
and just Pawn to C5 we have D countries
on C5 and this is where the game really
takes an interesting turn what Magnus
should play is B captures on C5 or if he
wants to be completely safe this is what
he should play uh as Queen captures on
C5 is impossible you can never cap run
C5 because just Bishop captures an F3
and also opens up an attack on the
bishop and D3 so your opponent C5 even
though it's undefended it's actually
defended by a tactic and it will survive
for a very long time yeah probably
indefinitely but after the captures on
C5 Magnus played Knight to the D7 he
gives up more material
uh for some rapid development but this
is not the the the best way to go about
it uh and uh if uh Alien left finds C6
then uh life for magnets will be
incredibly difficult point is that after
uh Knight C5 there's B4 of course
there's B4 Knight captures on D3 Queen
captures and now let's say queen E7 goes
after the B4 Pawn with check but you
don't care about it you just Castle to
safety uh and then if Queen captures on
B4 you just um uh continue pushing your
Pawn or even better you push E4 you
attack the bishop and now if Queen
captures on B4 with check you play
Knight to D2 you guard your E4 Pawn as
it's now attacked by the queen and by
the bishop and after some like Bishop
captures on A2 you will play Queen C2
and now you are attacking the bishop and
also you have a pass Pawn that's ready
to go to C7 so this would be a very nice
uh position for white most likely a
winning one but okay in the game he
Advanced the Ponte E4 instead of Pawn to
C6 and not magnet displays Bishop to C6
and this is blitz so of course it's
impossible to find all of these ideas
I'm just showing it as uh positions are
really really awesome uh if you've got
Bishop to B7 might be a little bit
better C6 is impossible because of Rook
to C8 but now Magnus plays Bishop to C6
instead of B7 and now just uh C captress
on V6 and again his Bishop is hanging he
plays Rook the C8 but now just B
captures on A7 he is not afraid of um
and the bishop moving uh so Queen to A5
with check Queen to C3 and now comes
Queen captures on A7 Magnus grabs the
past A7 Pawn Castles by Liam lit and now
Knight the F6 we have Pawn to A3 now
preparing to start marching those pawns
forward and Magnus doesn't really have a
better move uh than Bishop capture Sunny
for it's it's grabbing a pawn as the
queen on C3 will be attacked but even
though it's the the best move it doesn't
really give black all that much because
Liam of course gives up the queen so
Queen Queen captures on C8 Rock captures
Rook captures with check King to H7 and
now Rook to D1 defending his Bishop here
and after Magnus traded his captors and
captures Queen to B7 Rook to C2 was
played and now you have this position uh
where uh White has Five Pawns black has
four pawns but uh White also has two
Rooks for the queen so upper pawn and
two Rooks for the queen is definitely a
sufficient compensation and also the the
A and B pawns are passed Pawn so if you
can start pushing those pawns even if
you have to give up one of them uh you
should be winning so it's gonna be hard
for Magnus to pull this off but on the
other hand the queen and the Knight make
a deadly combo uh it's a very very hard
to fend off a queen in the night air
queen and the bishop not so much because
like if you have a queen and Bishop on a
light Square on a light diagonal you put
a knight on F3 and the Queen and version
battery is useless but if you have a
queen at night it's much much more
difficult to defend so here Ponte E5
Magnus that wants to create some
pressure pushing the E and F pawns Rook
the E3 and now Knight the G4 attacking
and defending Rook e to E2 and now Pawn
to E4 with Knight the D2 and pawn to F5
so Magnus starts making progress here H3
attacks the Knight Knights the E5 and
now Knights the C4 offers a trade of
knights which Magnus declines as he
should Knights to D3 and now Pawn to B4
uh very very good stuff here uh Queen to
A6 a beautiful paralyzing move by Magnus
this is uh this really paralyzes
everything because the The Rook cannot
move because it defends the Knight the
Knight cannot move because it defends
the pawn uh pawns cannot move as they
will be captured so there really isn't a
good move you can play here so Rook e to
D2 and now Pawn to F4 we have Knight the
B2 sorry Knight to B2 offering a trade
of knights and this Magnus should
decline very loudly he should play
something like Knight to E5 or Knights
the E1 just declined that trade but
Magnus got greedy for the pawn and he
played the queen captures on A3 and like
we said you don't need two points you
only need one pawn and you need a rook
behind that pass pawn and now uh Liana
just captures on D3 which also
disconnects the pawns Now Pawn captures
on D3 is played and Rook the B2 enough
from that position where you had a queen
and Knight and like we said Queen and
Knight are a deadly combo because for
white that Knight didn't really do all
that much for black that night was
incredible now uh Magnus really doesn't
have all that much to try here I mean
there's a rook on B dude there's a Pawn
on B4 Liam they will just start pushing
it and at some point you will probably
have to put a queen behind the pawn if
you want to block it so Pawn to F3
Magnus will create some further
weaknesses with Pawn to B5 just starts
advancing that pawn even though G
characters on F3 is objectively better
this is blitz so Queen to A1 with check
King to H2 now comes F characters on G2
King cap actress and queen to E1 now
going for some sort of
Perpetual checking idea uh Pawn to B6
and now Queen to E4 with check we have
Pawn to F3 and queen to G6 with check we
have King to F2 and now uh there is only
one move that doesn't lose the game for
Magnus so feel free to pause the video
and try to find it as I mean it's it's a
very lovely position because if you're
playing this if you have a seconds on
the clock you know you're you're playing
Blitz it's a very very hard to imagine
that you will spot this but you are
imagining in your own home very
comfortable watching this on your
smartphone or on your TV or on your
computer and you will enjoy if you are
able to solve this one so I have at it
uh while I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting that you
have to put the queen on the proper
diagonal and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Queen to D6
Magnus did not find this he played Queen
to G5 which is similar but not quite
with Queen to D6 you gain access to the
H2 square and that is the most important
thing here yeah because now if let's say
you play King to G2 to avoid this then
you repeat Queen to G6 and you don't
care if you try something else let's say
you advance the pawn pawn to B7 now you
have Queen to H to check and you will
always be able to check the white king
uh for example if if King that E1 you
can even check mating Queen to G1 is
Checkmate so the King has to go for
example the E3 now you play Queen to E5
check if King captures on D3 Queen to D6
with check if you go to C2 then Queen to
C5 with check if King the D1 then you
repeat Queen to G1 check if the King
goes up the board you play Queen to C5
check and if King the B1 again Queen to
G1 check King to A2 and again Queen to
A7 check so as long as you continue
checking along this diagonal you will
always have a check to give however
after King to F2 Magnus played Queen to
G5 which seems like you will be able to
to check the white king also
indefinitely but not quite limit just
pushes Pawn to V7 and now Magnus
realizes what he has done Queen to C5
with check King to F1 and now uh there
are no more ideas for black
unfortunately you cannot reach the H1
Square in that line that we've shown you
were on H2 so King to H1 you could just
continue checking even a nice Perpetual
Queen H1 Queen H2 Queen H1 H2 or if the
king starts marching then you just
continue checking along this diagram
like we've shown here you have nothing
Magnus just played Queen to E3 and he
was in this position unmove 42 that
Magnus Carlsen resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
even if you give this check just King
moves King to G2 and that's it there are
no more useful checks next move white
gets a queen into the game but after
Queen to E3 again just B8 Queen this
could this could be a possible
continuation I know most of you don't
need this but some of you may be new to
chess so you might be interested in how
this would be played out let's say queen
captures an F3 with checking G1 but now
there are no more useful checks Queen
covers the G3 Square you can't play
Queen to D1 uh you could capture an H3
but then white would just centralize the
queen and the black is pretty much
almost if Queen G4 Rook to G2 and that's
it that's game over
uh so yeah very nicely done uh by um
Quang Liam Lee who bounces back in the
match like I said uh first two games
that were decisive in the rapid section
Magnus won the first one then Liam
retaliated then game three and four into
the draw then Magnus wins the first
Blitz game uh and then uh Alien
retaliates uh in the second Blitz game
which forced Armageddon where Magnus had
the white pieces and then in in the
Armageddon Magnus one with the white
pieces it was a it was a very nice game
uh lilium basically just tried a really
really hard to play for a draw he even
gave up some material just to hold to
onto a draw from the from the very start
but it didn't work out all that well so
Magnus wins just not at the full three
points and it was a great opportunity
for Duda to catch up to him but he
played against pragnananda and he was
unable to beat him they also went into
Armageddon uh which ended in a draw but
Prague had the black pieces so frog uh
you know wins the match after all and
also before I end the video I would just
like to show you one very nice position
it was posted on Twitter by David Lada
so this is the position if you guys are
interested in an extra puzzle I thought
you guys might be because it's it's
truly a nice one he said I was breaking
my head over this position during my
lunch break it's made in two for white
uh obviously uh so yeah that's the
position try and solve it I will not
give you the answer if you are able to
solve it yourselves because it's it's
really nice then you are allowed to
comment on it in the in the comment
section below but don't don't just spoil
it for for everyone if you didn't solve
it yourself
uh so yeah that's the game and a little
bit of info and a nice extra puzzle for
you guys to enjoy uh hope you hope you
enjoyed that as well I would like to
thank Harry Barton Mario Francis air
Carmen polyphronium and Sinister Pawn
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day